los bloques comprimen un resorte entre
ellos cuando los bloques se liberan del
reposo el resorte empuja los bloques y
los separa con lo que el bloque up de
0.75 kilogramos sube una rampa de 30
grados a la izquierda y el bloque bm de
0.25 kilogramos se mueve a la derecha a
una velocidad final
esta es la velocidad final que obtiene
el bloque bm de 3 metros sobre segundo
supone que la fricción es despreciable
cuál de estas es la mejor estimación de
la distancia máxima de que se deslizó
hacia arriba el bloque a en la rampa
bien pues pausa el vídeo y piénsalo ok
vamos a trabajarlo juntos bien primero
vamos a imaginarnos qué es lo que pasa
aquí tenemos el bloque am y ven y los
comprimimos así que existe una energía
almacenada en el resorte y después
cuando lo soltamos sabemos que ven se
mueve hacia la derecha
que se mueve hacia la izquierda así que
la ley de la conservación del momento
tendrá un papel muy importante porque es
inicialmente el sistema a ibm se
encuentra en reposo la velocidad de cada
uno de estos bloques es cero sin
importar sus masas y eso significa que
el momento total para el sistema a ipem
es igual a cero así que aunque lo
soltamos ibex se mueve a la derecha y se
mueve a la izquierda el momento total de
este sistema es cero y podemos usar esto
para conocer la velocidad de amd cuando
se desliza hacia la izquierda
horizontalmente y después usando esa
velocidad podremos pensar en cuál es su
energía cinética porque una vez
conociendo la energía cinética podemos
pensar en que cuando el bloque sube por
la rampa toda esa energía se convierte
en energía potencial y así podremos
saber qué tan alto llegará en la rampa y
a partir de ese punto y el ángulo de
inclinación podré
calcular la distancia
bien hagamos eso empecemos con la ley de
la conservación del momento sabemos que
después de soltar los bloques tenemos
que el momento de app más el momento
debe debe de ser igual a cero porque la
suma de los momentos era cero cuando se
encontraban en reposo cuando
descomprimía el resorte podemos decir
que el momento de amd es igual a la masa
de a que sabemos que es de 0.75
kilogramos por la velocidad que no
conocemos así que le escribiré como ven
subíndice f
qué significa velocidad final de a y
esto tiene que estar en metros por
segundo recuerda más la masa debe que es
de 0.25 kilogramos
la velocidad debe que es de tres metros
por segundo
esto tiene que ser igual a 0 ahora sólo
necesitamos despejar esta velocidad como
nos quedaría vamos a ver esta parte es
igual a 0 puntos 75 kilogramos metro por
segundo
y si lo restamos de ambos lados de la
ecuación nos queda que 0.75 kilogramos
por la velocidad de amd cuando se libera
el bloque es igual a menos 0.75
kilogramos
metro por segundo y si ahora dividimos a
ambos lados entre 0.75 kilogramos del
lado izquierdo nos queda la velocidad de
amd y del lado derecho nos queda menos
12 kilogramos se cancelan así que nos
queda menos 1 metro por segundo entonces
cuando el bloque se libera del resorte
su velocidad es igual a menos un metro
por segundo pero qué significa el signo
negativo bueno cuando algo se mueve
hacia la derecha es positivo como es el
caso de tres metros por segundo pero
hacia la izquierda
no es negativo así que el bloque am se
mueve hacia la izquierda a 1 metro por
segundo
ahora usemos esta información para
calcular qué tan alto llega el bloque la
rampa suponiendo que la fricción es
despreciable y además que no ocurre nada
en este punto en el mundo real podría
rebotar un poco pero vamos a suponer que
ese no es un factor importante entonces
cuando el bloque am se mueve hacia la
izquierda a un metro por segundo toda la
energía cinética se convierte en energía
potencial a una cierta altura supongamos
que una vez que toda la energía cinética
se convierte en energía potencial el
bloque up se encuentra a una altura h
cuál será la energía potencial en ese
punto bueno la energía potencial será
igual a la masa de a por el campo
gravitacional que es aproximadamente 9.8
metros por segundo al cuadrado pero lo
podemos redondear a 10 metros por
segundo al cuadrado
por la altura esto es lo que tendremos
una vez que toda la energía cinética se
convierte en energía potencial y esto
debe de ser igual a la cantidad de
energía cinética que tenemos en este
punto que es un medio de la masa por la
velocidad al cuadrado así que tenemos un
medio por la masa de amd por la
velocidad de amd al cuadrado que en este
caso es menos un metro por segundo y
esto al cuadrado bien ahora podemos
dividir ambos lados entre la masa de amd
y bueno menos uno al cuadrado es igual a
uno así que para despejar h podemos
dividir ambos lados
entre g con lo que nos quedará que la
altura es igual a un medio entre g y
esto nos queda en metros pero cuánto
será bueno si decimos que g es igual a
diez metros por segundo al cuadrado
porque aquí solamente nos preguntan cuál
es la mejor estimación entonces esto es
igual a uno
entre 2 por 10 es decir esto es igual a
1 entre 20 y por lo tanto h es
aproximadamente igual a 0.05 metros
y tal vez puedan pensar oh ahí está la
respuesta pero recuerden que no nos
están pidiendo la altura nos preguntan
por la distancia así que ahora
necesitamos usar un poco de
trigonometría qué función
trigonométricas se calcula con el cateto
opuesto del ángulo y la hipotenusa
porque aquí tenemos un triángulo
rectángulo claro el seno entonces el
seno de 30 grados es igual al cateto
opuesto que en este caso es h entre d y
ahora ya sabemos que h es igual a 0.05 y
para el seno de 30 grados no necesitamos
una calculadora porque es muy fácil el
seno de 30 grados es igual a un medio
entonces nos queda que un medio es igual
a 0.05 entre d así que podemos
multiplicar ambos lados por d y así nos
queda que de entre 2 es igual a 0.05 y
al multiplicar ambos lados por 2 nos
queda que t es aproximadamente igual a 0
y digo aproximadamente porque
redondeamos el valor de g
esta es nuestra respuesta por lo tanto
voy a seleccionar la y hemos acabado nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo